في مواقع مرموقة عالميا اخرها في
اجهزة ابل الامريكية. تايوان
المتخصص في امن مواقع بعد
اكتشافه اكثر من ثمانمائة ثغرة
المياه الخليجية بعد ان انقطعت
اتصالات الملاحة بها مؤكدة نفي
الكونجرس. هل ينج ترامب من
الملاحقات القانونية وهل ستؤثر
كوريا الشمالية المحصنة بقوة.
قامت الامريكية والكورية
تطلق اول طلقة تجاه الصين دون اي
رد بال. سينتظر ابناء العم سام
الصنع وصلت عليها من طهران هذا
الشهر لاستخدامها في الحرب في
نيويورك وتفتيش منزله في فلوريدا
ولجنة بواشنطن بشأن احداث اقتحام
وصراخ استمرت هذه المشاهد
المؤلمة لساعات ليظهر الصدر هنا.
الجزائر عن اتصالها بشكل مباشر
مع الشاب مواز عبدالقادر الشاب
يقترب. وتشتد عاصفة التصريحات
الاسرائيلية حيث صرح وزير الدفاع
ام لا، لكنه وجد انصاتا من
الادارة الامريكية فيما يتعلق
المسيرات من نوع مهاجر ستة وشاهد
ليرد مسؤول كبير في الادارة
انصاره ستين دقيقة للانسحاب من
الشارع ليخمد بعدها نرى الفتنة
الثوري قام بايقاف واطلاق سراح
سفينة امريكية غير مأهولة في
الجنوبية بتحركات عسكرية
لاستفزاز بيونج يانج والمجنون
الهاون والار بي جي ليغطي على
اصواتها صوت صافرات الاسعاف
وقنصليات اوروبية في المغرب.
قالت مصادر اعلامية ان الحرس
الجمعية الايطالية المغربية
للدفاع عن حقوق الانسان لرفع
هل يعني ذلك اننا قريبون من حافة
كارثة نووية. ما رأيكم انتم؟
دعوى قضائية في محكمة العدل
الدولية الاوروبية على سفارات
وعشرين ساعة دامية كانت مليئة
باصوات الرصاص الحي وقذائف
نعم. جزر سليمان. التي لطالما
كانت حليفة للولايات المتحدة
ودخل معه حلف كواد. هذا الحلف
الذي اقلق اصحاب العيون الضيقة
الخلاف والتناحر ساقوم باعلان
خلو المنصب حسب الدستور العراقي
وتحميلهم المسئولية. وهنا نتمنى
من اهلنا في العراق ان يحكموا
عكس روسيا. لترسو الصين على جزر
سليمان وتعلن عن توسع نفوذها.
علينا حصر السلاح بيد الدولة
فقط. اذا ارادوا الاستمرار في
فبماذا سترد واشنطن. العراق على
شفا كارثة. عاش العراق اربعا
على شعبيته السياسية اعلنت
المديرية العامة لاتصالات
المتعلقة بتوريد الغاز. لكن لا
يمكنها الوفاء بتلك الالتزامات
الامريكية ان روسيا تواجه فشلا
كبيرا مع طائرات مسيرة ايرانية
مسيرة صينية حلقت فوق جزيرة
صغيرة تسيطر عليها تايوان قرب
الاسرائيلي انه لا يعرف ان كان
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران سيوقع
لاحداث وقعت قبل مائة عام.
تحقيقات حول شركات ترامب في
بانها لن تسمح لاي قطع عسكرية
امريكية بالرسو على لتصيب واشنطن
الساحل الصيني. جاء بعد وقت قصير
من اعلان رئيسة تايوان انها امرت
الجيش باتخاذ اجراءات مضادة قوية
ضد ما وصفته بالاستفزازات
وجه بكين. لتطلق تايوان اولى
رصاصاتها التحذيرية على طائرة
خلال ست دقائق. واليوم هنا
الكاظمي يصرح احداث بغداد تحتم
بموقف اسرائيل من الاتفاق. ليأتي
الرد من الرئيس الايراني قائلا.
ان صدقوا بتهديداتهم. والتي اصبح
الامريكان لا يعيرونها اي اهتمام
قيمة الاسلحة تبلغ مليارا ومائة
مليون دولار وتشمل ستين صاروخا
اردوغان يتهم دولا بدعم اليونان
لخوض حرب ضد تركيا بالوكالة في
السلامة النووية في فنلندا عن
رصد تسرب اشعاعي مشيرة الى ان
عقولهم فالعراق ملك للجميع.
الحلم الايراني يقترب. حلم ايران
الجيش الروسي عن مقتل اكثر من
خمسمائة جندي اوكراني حسب تصريحه
يستعد لتجربة نووية هي السابعة
في تاريخ كوريا الشمالية. بعد
الاوروبي وروسيا. اذا ما الذي
يعنيه ذلك يا روبرت يعلن هنا
اراضيها الكريملين يهدد. روسيا
سترد بقوة وتتمسك بالتزاماتها
ايران محاولة استيلائها على
المركب الامريكي. الرئيس التركي
وبعد اعلان بعض الدول الاوروبية
نيتها منع السياح الروس من دخول
منتقدا خروج انصاره عن النهج
الذي خطه واعتذر للعراقيين وامهل
خيبة امل اذ وجدوا ان بكين قد
فرضت هيمنتها على هذه الجزر
تنجح ولن تنجح في المستقبل وفق
تعبيره لتعلن ايران تسليم مئات
الصينية. لقد دخل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن البيت الابيض
دولة اوروبية ترصد تسربا اشعاعيا
بالهواء. نعم. هذه الدولة هي
اوكرانيا. الاحداث والتطورات.
على بعد عشرين كيلو مترا من حدود
قيام فرنسا برفض منح المغاربة
تأشيرات سفر بشكل متكرر دعت
استراتيجية خداع اوكرانية جديدة
نجحت في تضليل عشرة صواريخ روسية
مضادا للسفن. ولا ننسى ان هجوم
الصين سيكون عن طريق السفن هذا
الامريكية اليها. اذ تلقت واشنطن
اخطارا من قيادة جزر سليمان
بيع اسلحة لتايوان. حيث نقلت
صحيفة بوليتكو عن مصادر مطلعة ان
الامريكية. اليوم تعلن تعليق
كافة زيارات القطع البحرية
بليسيتسك الكل يحبس انفاسه
ويستعد لاختبار صاروخ الشيطان
كل هذا الرعب يا ابناء
الكريملين. وزير الخارجية الروسي
تقويض العلاقات الدولية. هنا
واشنطن بوست بافخاخ من خشب لا
تايوان تطلق رصاصتها الاولى. لن
نخاف منكم بعد اليوم وكانها في
فالتهديدات الاسرائيلية لايقاف
برنامج ايران النووي السلمي لم
ام من خوف ما متابعينا وهنا
ادارة العجوز بايدن تعلن عزمها
الاكبر بوزن مائتين وعشرين طنا
وبطول عشرين مترا وبعرض ثلاثة
نعم طورت امريكا انظمة صواريخ
هايمرز لتصل لثلاثمائة كيلومتر
روسية هي الاكثر رعبا في تاريخ
الحروب. اوكرانيا تعلن عن طريقة
جناحيه. رياح الموت تقترب.
الخبير روسي ايجورني كولين يتحدث
كميات صغيرة من النظائر المشعة
كانت متواجدة في عينات الهواء.
وارسلتها لاوكرانيا. هذا الامر
لن نسكت عليه. هنا قاعدة
امتار. هو من الصوت ويحمل في
احشائه عشرة رؤوس نووية قادر على
يمكن للصواريخ والمسيرات الروسية
ان تميزها عن الحقيقة.
بسبب العقوبات المفروضة ومن رياح
الباروت الى رياح الموت العاتية.
رد بكين ليتدخلوا ام ان هناك
حسابات اخرى. شاركونا برأيكم.
عملاقة. رئيس اللجنة العسكرية
للاتحاد الاوروبي روبرت بريجر
ارسال قوات في مهمات تدريبية لا
يعني اشارات حرب بين الاتحاد
الاقرب لمحطة زابروتش النووية
الاوكرانية حيث كشفت هيئة مراقبة
الرحمة. تايوان تطلق رصاصة
الاولى تجاه الصين فبماذا سترد
عليكم جميعا ان تستعدوا لشيطان
بوتين الاكبر. مفاجأة عسكرية
فلم نعلم حتى هذه اللحظة سبب
سكوت الصين هل هو نابع من حكمة
جديدة لاسقاط الصواريخ الروسية.
والاتحاد الاوروبي يزعج بوتين
سيرجي لافروف. الغرب يحاول اعادة
الهيمنة على العالم من خلال
محو مدينة كمدينة تكساس في مدة
لا تتجاوز اثنتي عشرة ثانية. ما
وشيك بينما الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يغضب ايران العراق على شفا كارثة
جديدة وهكر جزائري يكرمه الغرب
وعبد المجيد تبون يضعه تحت
بهذا القرار ليرد بوتين بقطع
شريان اوروبا والمانيا تطلب
بكين؟ والمجنون يتخذ اجراء نوويا
لتحذر واشنطن من تصادم عسكري